from characters surviving fatal wounds
to zombies with super speed there are
still some aspects of The Walking Dead
that simply can't be explained here are
just some of the strange inconsistencies
and giant plot holes
in the very first episode Rick Grimes
awakes from a coma to find himself in
the middle of a zombie apocalypse while
this certainly makes for a dramatic
series kickoff it's never made clear how
Rick managed to survive up to that point
prior to the apocalypse Rick was a
sheriff's deputy he sustained a gunshot
wound in the line of duty which put him
in a coma for four to five weeks
according to Walking Dead showrunner
Dave Erickson that's a lot of time to be
in a coma without medical attention in
the web series The Oath we learned that
a doctor stayed at the hospital after
the outbreak and took care of the
patients for a while myos is to people
who need help
and that holds up now
more than ever
this helps explain how Rick survives but
he still wakes up alone and malnourished
which implies that he's been without
medical care for a while it must be
magic
the outbreak happens on August 26 2010
yet Rick and the Gang somehow find a
2011 Hyundai Tucson in season 2. this
means that the group found a vehicle
that wasn't invented yet let alone
mass-produced they drive the Kiwi green
SUV around for two seasons using it to
escape from hordes of zombies but it
never gets a dent or a speck of blood on
it the vehicle stays sparkling clean in
a post-apocalyptic world because of a
product placement deal with Hyundai the
contract stated that the vehicle
couldn't break down get excessively
dirty or be used to run over zombies
while this makes sense for Hyundai the
pristine car looks out of place in the
world of the show but hey if we were
living in a post-apocalyptic world and
found a time traveling car that was
always cleaned and never broke down we'd
drive it around too
Rick and the rest of the survivors are
in Georgia for most of the series
Georgia summers are hot and humid but it
gets cold and snows during winter
despite this we hardly ever see the
survivors deal with snow in The Walking
Dead in fact there isn't a single
snowflake until the season nine finale
best bet is to go old school to keep
toasty at advise initiating winter one
ice storm protocol in 2022 showrunner
Angela Kang told Cinema Blend one of the
things we were trying to do this season
is play with the rhythm of the
storytelling a little bit and hopefully
do some things that we hadn't done
before between fending off Walkers and
hostile groups of people the characters
already have a lot to deal with but
seeing them Brave the elements up the
ante even more since snowfall only adds
to the drama it's interesting that so
little of the show takes place during
winter time
in season 8 Negan devises a plan for his
group to smear zombie guts on their
weapons infecting anyone unlucky enough
to be attacked by them Hilltop is going
to learn toe the line one somewhere
another Dead or Alive it sounds like a
pretty good plan except that it reveals
a huge plot hole about whether or not
zombie blood can infect people if
survivors get infected every time zombie
DNA enters their bloodstream there are
several instances in which characters
should have gotten infected but somehow
don't in season 2 episode 10 18 miles
out Shane gets trapped in a school bus
while fighting Walkers he cuts his hand
with a dirty knife and uses his blood to
distract them in season 7 episode 10 new
best friends Rick goes up against a
walker with spikes coming out of its
body his hand gets cut by one of the
blades which we can assume is covered in
infected blood since it's impaling the
zombie's body so which is it can zombie
blood infect survivors or not
you all submit to a blood test that's
the price of admission if not negan's
plan makes no sense and another thing
why haven't survivors smeared zombie goo
on themselves more often to avoid danger
they use this tactic to camouflage
themselves in seasons one and five and
of course there are the whisperers who
regularly wear zombie faces to blend in
with herds of the undead
from the group's Invincible Hyundai
Tucson to Daryl's iconic motorcycle the
survivors used a variety of vehicles
throughout the show but the story takes
place over a number of years and
gasoline has an expiration date so where
is this magic gas coming from RAC
limited a British automotive services
company confirmed this information in
2019 saying generally speaking petrol
has a shelf life of six months if stored
in a sealed container at 20 degrees
Celsius or just three months if kept at
30 degrees once you've put fuel in a
Jerry can or other containers you only
have a few months before the quality
starts to fall away even less if the
fuel is contaminated they go on to
explain that using old gasoline can
damage vehicles and impact their overall
performance however this isn't the only
reason why characters shouldn't be able
to drive in the show think about how
much maintenance vehicles require on a
regular basis flat tires dead batteries
and transmission problems are pretty
common problems even during a
non-apocalypse when you consider that
most of the vehicles in the show have
been sitting unattended for months or
years on end and not every group has a
mechanic watching the survivors cruise
around at will just doesn't add up
survivors in a post-apocalyptic world
would have way more to worry about than
Landscaping so why are there freshly
mowed lawns in the show the prison that
Rick and the Gang discovered in season 3
has a large well-maintained yard despite
no one taking care of it there are some
prisoners there when the group arrives
but they've been locked in the cafeteria
for months so they didn't have access to
the lawn was there a zombie landscaper
that still had the basic motor skills to
push a lawnmower across the field before
the show aired AMC released some rules
that all zombies in the show follow
which included this one zombies are not
dexterous they cannot pick up or use any
items more complex than a rock or a
stick so no weed whackers then during an
interview with Chris Hardwick in 2017
showrunner Scott M gimple finally
addressed this Enigma I am working on a
story okay all of these years why the
grass is cut will be answered it seems
like it'd be hard to carve out me time
in the middle of a zombie apocalypse yet
between between making Supply runs and
fighting for their lives the survivors
managed to maintain stylish haircuts
Carol for example rocks a pixie cut and
Negan shaves the sides of his head for
the most part the men do a great job of
grooming their facial hair whether
they're sporting a majestic
well-moisturized beard for just the
right amount of stubble but the ladies
of the show stay especially well groomed
in addition to keeping their eyebrows on
point there aren't any hairy legs or
armpits in sight they're smooth radiant
skin hints at a 10-step nightly routine
and an effortless no makeup makeup look
no matter how dire the situation all of
the survivors have stylish clothes that
fit them perfectly yes they're a bit
dirty and have some holes in them but
that kind of wear and tear could happen
over the course of a week-long camping
trip and can we talk about how great
everyone's teeth look maybe there were
salons and dentists in Alexandria but
the rest of the time it doesn't make
sense
foreign
there are many different types of
walkers in the Shell from those that
couldn't move around to those that
wandered back home and everything in
between but despite all the zombie
variants zombie children are weirdly
missing from the series for the most
part ironically the first zombie that
ever appears on the show is a little
girl in the very first episode Rick
tries talking to her but then she starts
getting aggressive and he has to shoot
her after that there are a handful of
other zombie kids such as Carol's
Daughter Sophia the governor's daughter
Penny and Noah's unnamed brother however
that's nothing compared to the hordes of
adult zombies that threaten the
survivors at every turn the scarcity of
zombie children is unusual especially
considering that in The Walking Dead
Universe everyone has the virus and
turns into a zombie after they die
whether or not they're bitten
the survivors face all kinds of danger
throughout the series including the
possibility of starvation at the
beginning of season 3 the group has been
on the run for a while and Carl is so
hungry that he almost resorts to eating
canned dog food there have even been
episodes when the group has to walk
miles on end like when they are trying
to find Terminus in season four but all
that extra cardio doesn't lead to any
weight loss when it comes to body weight
viewers have had questions about two
characters in particular Tara and Eugene
in a 2016 Instagram post Elena Masterson
who played Tara fired back at body
shamers and explained that she just had
a baby before filming season seven Josh
McDermott who played Eugene addressed
his own character's appearance during an
interview with Entertainment Weekly in
2018 saying it's hard to go from one
week to the next and you go well it
would be awesome if I was 30 pounds
lighter that's physically impossible no
one is saying that actors should be body
shamed or pressured to lose weight
however when the story of the show
involves extreme meager rations and
grueling Journeys on foot a little
makeup or CGI to temporarily slim down
the characters would make things much
more realistic
is Rick Immortal he's survived the
bleakest of situations like the bridge
incident in season 9 episode 5 what
comes after he's bleeding heavily after
being thrown off his horse and impaled
by a rebar in the previous episode
fading in and out of Consciousness he
leaves a huge herd of Walkers through a
bridge and sets off an explosion to
protect the rest of the survivors but
he's on the bridge with the herd when
this happens so his friends and family
assume he died in the explosion we later
learned that Rick somehow survived the
blast fell into the zombie infested
River below and washed up on shore
without drowning getting bitten or
losing a critical amount of blood we get
that the writers didn't want to kill
Rick off since he's the main character
but it's ridiculous how many injuries
this man can recover from any side
character would have died as soon as
they fell into the rebar or at the very
latest during the explosion
most of the walkers in the show are weak
slow unintelligent and uncoordinated
especially compared to the zombies and
franchises like 28 Days Later despite
this there are many instances when the
zombies act differently than usual some
of them are strong enough to
single-handedly crack glass break
through walls or drag a grown man away
when it comes to speed AMC's rules for
the show state that zombies can't Sprint
the fastest they can move is a quote
shambling run in addition they explain
that the ability to run is based on the
amount of time a zombie has been Undead
and how much Decay has set in however
there have been times when Walkers keep
Pace with characters running at full
speed one glaring example of this is in
the season 2 premiere what lies ahead
when Sophia is running for her life and
two Walkers are able to keep up with her
just fine and what about the zombies
varying levels of intelligence and
dexterity in the Show's first episode a
zombie returns home and tries to open
the door in the next episode a zombie
chasing after Rick and Glenn has the
wherewithal to climb over a chain-link
fence without breaking its legs these
instances are a far cry from Walkers
mindlessly stumbling around all day do
we chalk it up to Undead evolution
foreign